the cdc director dr rachelle wolinski
joins us right now good morning rachelle
how are you doing
i'm well good morning nate how are you
good now as we just heard some medical
experts think that there should be a
negative test requirement at the end of
the five-day isolation period why is
that not required
yeah really important question so let me
sort of go through the science that we
were looking at as we were making these
recommendations first is watching the
virus how does the virus behave and what
we do know is about 85 to 90 percent of
viral transmission happens in those
first five days which is why we really
want people to stay home during that
period of time and then mask for the
rest of the time to capture that last 10
to 15 percent we also know we're
expecting a large number of cases we've
seen that in other countries and many of
those cases may be asymptomatic or
mildly symptomatic so we want to be able
to get people back out if they're
feeling well but to also have them be
masked and finally we want to make sure
that when people isolate to the extent
that they can and are able to isolate
that they do so during that most
infectious period those first five days
to the question of why we didn't
request
recommend an antigen test first we know
a pcr test would not be viable because
that pcr can stay positive for up to 12
weeks for months and months
but for the antigen this is a really
important question and that is because
we don't know how this antigen performs
with regard to predicting
transmissibility towards the end of your
period of infection we know it performs
really well during that period where
you're initially infected but the fda
has not at all looked at whether that
correlate of your positive antigen
really does correlate with whether
you're transmissible or not so with a
negative antigen test we'd still ask you
to wear a mask with a positive antigen
test we'd still say you could wear a
mask and since it wasn't going to make a
difference in our recommendations we did
not recommend an antigen at that period
of time
i do have to ask you there are so many
places across this country where people
just aren't wearing masks now you're
asking them to wear masks how do we get
this across to people that you know if
you've been exposed or you've tested
positive you still have to wear that
mask for a certain period of time
right well and that's actually a really
important point and that is we really do
need people to follow these
recommendations to for them to work but
i would also say those people who are
not masking who are out and about are
probably not the ones who are isolating
either so what we really wanted to do is
make sure that these recommendations
were more easily followed we shortened
the time to encourage people to do the
right thing especially those who are
infected we don't want them out and
about when they are maximally infectious
dr welinski i want to get back to the
rapid antigen testing for a second if
they were more readily available in this
country would you have included a
testing requirement after that five day
period
so to be clear we have
we did not include a testing requirement
in isolation because we were not clear
it was not clear what we would do with
the information when we had it and
because the fda has not authorized that
antigen test for that use
we do absolutely recommend an antigen
test in our quarantine recommendations
for anybody who after they've been
exposed at five days so this really had
nothing to do with supply it had
everything to do with knowing what we
would do with the information when we
got it dr wilinski thank you so much for
joining us
thanks for having me